c'est en 1955 que maxnst artiste majeur
du surréalisme s'installe à UIM avec sa
compagne dorothéa taning peintre et
sculptrice à deux pas de chez Calder à
Sacher un couple d'artistes qui trouve
une vie apaisée en Touren dans une
lettre à un ami maxernst écrit il fait
beau calme et doux ici c'est dans son
atelier qu'il réalise un tableau
emblématique le jardin de la France ce
tableau a une curiosité c'estàdire que
c'est un tableau académique du 19e
siècle que maxer a acheté qui représente
une femme nue àongé cette femme nue il
en
conserve les parties des zones
éogènes du corps et il repeint sur ce
tableau un paysage local qui fait que
cette femme devient une île entre
l'Indre et la Loire le le jardin de la
France voilà c'est un tableau en fait
qui fait référence au sujet de l'abaye
de them c'estàd que c'est la femme
matrice la femme jardin qui représente
cet esprit de liberté puisque la femme
est nu l'appropriation ici en fait est
doubl c'est l'objet physique du tableau
avec cette femme nu et puis le sujet de
Rabé et de laab de tem depuis
l'acquisition de la maison de maxernst
et dorotha tanning en 2006 Dominique
marchez n'a cessé de et collecté une
documentation très riche sur l'artiste
allemand des mouvements Dada et
surréalistes une rencontre bouleversante
dans son itinéraire de vie
personnelle moi je suis né dans cette
région que j'y ai vécu adolescent que je
n'avais pas la connaissance de l'art à
15 ans j'ai pris ma ma mobylette pour
aller voir où était l'atelier de Calder
c'était mon mon premier mon premier choc
ma façon je dirais de tomber dans la
marmite hein et et puis après donc j'ai
j'ai fait tout un un parcours
autodidacte de de m'intéresser à l'art
de créer des lieux d'art et donc quand
on crée un lieu d'art ben c'est en fait
c'est de transmettre c'est d'avoir ce
rapport entre l'œuvre et le public donc
en acquirant cette maison c'était
vraiment pour la sauvegarder donc pour
en garder la mémoire parce qu'au fond
c'est du patrimoine qui est immatériel
il est physique à travers l'atelier la
maison les sculptures par exemple dans
dans ce mur mais il faut encore animer
je dirai le lieu la maison mais aussi le
jardin avec ses collages de basrelief du
19e au cœur du mur de la propriété sont
ouverts au public autre symbole de son
art la fontaine d'Amboise seul monument
conçu par maxerns pour l'espace public
en France à travers cette fontaine il y
a à la fois un remerciement à la France
et au maire d'Amboise Michel Debray
garde des saut qui à l'époque lui
accorde la nationalité française puis
aussi un
hommage à la grande figure à Amboise de
de Léonard de Vincy au cracheur au drôle
au génie c'est le nom de cette fontaine
inaugurée en 1968 un symbole de l'esprit
ludique de maxerns et un hommage au
génie le génie est un génie ailé c'est
un oiseau symboliquement ça représente
le génie de la liberté voilà c'est une
référence un petit peu au au Génie de la
Bastille à Paris mais surtout surtout
c'est une c'est un hommage à Léonard de
vin à son homme de Vitruve et si on
regarde ces grandes ailes elles sont
déployées de part et d'autrre elles
embrassent la ville d'Amboise de part et
d'autrre de clolcé et de la chapelle
Saint-Hubert du château royal où il est
inumé maxern s'est éteint à Paris en
1976 mais sa maison fait partie du
patrimoine culturel de la région elle a
reçu le label maison des illustres en
octobre 2016